I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to another
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
be doing another one of my favorite gigs
were review a website and give my
feedback so this one came in it's Forney
Tokra dito and why don't we check it out
helping people empowering them to make
better decisions so let's see what it's
all about and hopefully I can get some
good feedback so neato credito balance
transfer calculator take control of your
finances what do all those credit card
balances offers mean neato pretty to
help users get through the mess of junk
mail turn it into a true credit leaf
opportunity this is the only credit tool
you'll ever need on any platform with
neat Oprah dito you only need to set up
one username and password to commute
across multiple devices both mobile and
desktop okay not quite sure what this is
all about what the balance transfers are
I guess is when you're on a credit card
trying to move from one credit card to
another my first thought here is
obviously it's a mobile application
we're showing it here you know you might
want to improve the logo a little bit it
looks okay but you know if you go on
something like 99designs you can get a
pretty good logo set up for you you
might want to work on the wording here
just to more clearly explain what it is
a new value you bring I've never had to
transfer credit from one credit card to
another so I haven't I haven't gotten
these offers so I'm not your target user
which is fine but you want to make sure
that it's easily understandable by your
target audience so even things like
having two blue plurals together so this
would be what do all those credit card
balance offers mean and then tap it into
the pain point a little bit more so I'm
I'd be assuming somebody who's really
struggling with that especially credit
card debt there they're really just
trying to figure out how to get out of
that right and how to pay off the credit
cards on time and not have a crazy high
interest rate so focusing here on
sorting through the massive junk mail I
don't see this as a big convenience play
it's more understanding right trying to
understand the offer what it means and
how
they can make the best financial
decision for them so turn it into a true
credit relief opportunity it's good it
kind of says what you do a little bit
but it doesn't hit the pain point right
you're talking about the mess of junk
mail that's more of a pain point than
true credit relief opportunity but I
flipped them like I tap into this pain
point a lot more because I would assume
somebody who is really struggling with
that would do anything they could and
they deal with junk mail but the
convenience play is not what they're
necessarily looking for it's great to
make it more convenient but they want to
they want help trying to understand what
they did wrong and how they mean how
they can fix it so I'd rejigged this a
little bit more it's not painful enough
the value proposition could be a lot
stronger here this part here about
having one username password you don't
need to have that it's it's not adding
so much value right to the to the users
who are going to be signing up for this
that's not their primary concern right
how many you know time to have to enter
in their username and password and what
device it works on this might work great
as a mobile app might be better just as
a website I don't know I mean you can
see what has a better response rate but
I definitely spend more time here trying
to figure out the value proposition and
tap it into the pain point of your
target audience instead of just talking
about what it does like this is a
technical feature most people won't care
about this but if you talk about the the
benefits of your application then you
might start to get more people signing
up for so the next thing I died on here
is some kind of testimonials who has
used this you know how much did they
like it how much did help them you know
they're now saving thousands of dollars
or you know whatever the benefit is of
using your application show pictures of
real people who've used it and are
getting value from it that's going to be
a big opportunity to get people to want
to sign up for what you're doing so i
don't see any testimonials here even if
you're giving it to your friends or
people you know for free at the
beginning just to get some testimonials
it as it adds a lot of credibility and
so definitely add some of those and make
that will really
here the next thing is to try to get
some media I try to support the
application by submitted to the
different directories and different
awards and there's always those posts
coming out about the top 10 or top 100
no financial applications you should be
on there right I'm assuming this is a
good application really help people you
should be on there and then you can have
a little link with the image that says
you made this list or that list again it
just adds a little more credibility so
if i'm coming to here and it sees that
people have used it they've got good
value from it you've been featured on
all these different lists then a much
more likely to want to kind of take that
next step with you let's keep going
learn a little bit more but what you're
doing so let's click on the about page
and see what shows up help reduce
confusion on credit card balance
transfers no this is this is better
helping reduce confusion on credit card
balance transfer so I know what it's for
you know if I have a credit card balance
transfer in here you did it correctly so
instead of balances transfers his
balance transfer when my home pages it
was incorrect but you're talking about
reducing confusion which is a lot better
a lot stronger value proposition than
reducing the mess of junk mail so you
know reading through has never been a
tool like this to help you see through
all the percentages and glimmer perks
until now I don't know what glimmer
perks are maybe that's something that's
somebody who is having this issue with
their credit cards would know if that's
something you just made up then I would
remove it you want to be careful using
jargon or terminology that other people
may not understand so i'd probably take
that out keep reading an app designed to
do the work for you and help you make a
more educated financial decision and its
technology is patented
these are good maybe a separate
statements you know as a user I don't
care if your technology is patented
right it's not adding a lot of value to
me if its patented or not I care about
the results that I can get if I'm an
investor then I care if your technology
is patented or maybe even a reporter
looking to do a story on you so you
might you know have that in a different
section because the value to the
customer is does it work and does it
help you know reduces confusion that
you're talking about so if its patent it
or not doesn't make a difference so
again you only want to put the
information in that will hit people
really strongly so you might want to
just do some testing with your copy or
have somebody help you out in writing a
little bit better copy this little more
marketing focused and sometimes just
stepping out of the business and having
somebody else look at it can give you
some insights because a lot of times
entrepreneurs are so in their business
that can be hard to to write good copy
let's go down so else we got this is
good about the hollow works I like the
screenshots there was a video on the
other page we can look at that's great
so take the balance transfer you've
received and enter the loan amount along
with other information that was included
with it you know credito will then
calculate the offer and show you the
real feel rate of what you could be
paying for your loan so again i've never
heard of real feel rate if if that's a
standard term then great but otherwise
if you're making that up you might want
to just explain a little bit more about
what that is and discover if the balance
offer is right for you yeah maybe here
it's you know pick the right one pick
the one that makes the most sense it
gives you the lowest rate gives you the
best offer so it's okay you know this
helps me if this this page is better
than the home page it helps break it
down a little bit more but again it
could be warded better in terms of
explaining what you do and also the
benefits that are being offered to the
customer I want to learn a bit more
about who you guys are too look if I
click on an about page I want to learn a
little bit about the company and that
will help you be able to convert more
people as well if it's showing your face
and a big smile and friendly and you
tell your story and maybe you
credit card issues and this is why you
did it no tell a little bit of a
personal story it's an advantage of
entrepreneurs have over bigger companies
as we can make it more personal and tell
their own story and have our passion
come through and so if you were able to
do that people could hopefully relate to
what you're talking about and they're
spending more time on your website
they're more likely to take that next
step and go get the Opera visit the site
so I definitely have a little bit more
about the business who's behind it and
why you started it up we've got more so
your account I'm assuming is login yeah
about we looked at support let's look at
the blog see what's on the blog
infographic credit card debt in America
so this is outdated September second you
know where we're almost in 2013 as i'm
writing this video it's creating this
video sorry what's december you know
28th right now so this is really
outdated here this looks like a good
post so i don't know if you created this
it's a nice infographic talking about
that hopefully explain some of your
benefits until you created yourself
that's great but if you can have a blog
you want to make sure you keep it
updated with information so you have two
posts in here from August and then
September so I look creating the content
strategy will help your search engine
optimization to get traffic coming to
the site learning about what you guys
are all about and hopefully signing up
for your services so definitely a little
bit more there we also have privacy in
terms let's do a quick look to see
what's happening here and so this is
great you know people you know with any
app there is information is given away
so it's great that you're explaining how
you're using it and then also what the
terms are so it's in a pretty easy to
find place sir you know at the bottom
it's easy to read it's not buried so for
people who do care a lot about that it's
great that you're you're showing it so
good job on that one here it says
website designed by spaceship media I
know what developers love putting this
kind of stuff in this is going to help
them with their SEO you know unless you
made a deal with them or unless have
given you some kind of fee I would take
out this link that goes to their website
because it doesn't give you any added
value here so next is our social
channels so we got facebook we got
Twitter we got google plus and we got
youtube so let's take a quick look
what's happening here facebook so we've
got 1200 likes that's great looking
through December eighteenth so they were
this month not bad and then october
eight so tember first August first okay
so you're posting once a month basically
there's no engagement really happening
in your posts so you know it could be
hard for for this kind of stuff but I'd
like to see a little bit more posting on
here looks like an August you posted a
couple April March would be good to have
more of a constant driving strategy here
that you can use on your blog and then
also on your social channels probably
start to see the same here so Twitter
one in November one October one
September or 23 in September oh and
that's it so challenge here is somebody
comes and finds you here there's no
activity you know it doesn't look good
it doesn't look like it's a real company
a real business with a lot of interest
so it reduces my interest in working
with the business if I see that there's
no activity happening on them it's
probably the same thing google plus 1
post fine YouTube not as important to
keep this as updated but it's still good
to have so you've had some views yo
couple videos but the facebook twitter
google+ they can all tie together you
know if you just have a blog strategy
here you use your blog you get regular
post going up and then you share them
through your social channels you don't
have to be a you know a social media
guru but just keep those channels
updated and monitor them and when people
talk to you you can write back because
that's it's a cheap way to market your
business and great way to reach out to
people and hopefully get people signing
up for your app so hopefully that helps
that was my kind of initial thoughts on
this program but those of you watching
if you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below makes you want to do
more than for you and if you have a
question about this website neat Oprah
dito or comment about your own site feel
free to leave it in the comments section
below I always check those out and if
you're interested in the fiber gigs as
well for you know getting review of your
website I'll leave the
link in the comment section below thank
you and we'll see you soon
you